Yeah, let's go to the next step. It's the Google Cloud platform virtual machine setup
You can use these guides step by step. Here is a screenshots how to do it, but yeah, let me do it
Let me do it in live format. So when you start you will start with this
Welcome page and you can just type virtual machine here virtual machine instances you go here
Let's check what our first steps activate free trial open. Okay, we've done that
Yeah, we need to first things first. We need to create a firewall rule. What's this firewall rule is doing? It's
basically open your virtual machine to the rest of the network since miners and validators
why it's decentralized because it's the
separate machine separate people in the different parts of the world and they should
Be able to speak with each other
So this is why we should create the firewall rule that will open your virtual machine to the rest of the world
Let's go and create this firewall rule. You can just type it here
Firewall rules and we need to click there create the firewall rule here. Let's do this
Our name I use the name allow TCP 80 91 80 91 is number of the port
Okay, we've done that
Then we need to do we need to choose
Name done direction direction in grass action on match
Default stay and our targets all instances in the network, right all instances in the network and we should
Use here done
non non allow specified protocol imports click TCP put
1891 and
It should be it. Yes, and we click create. I already have this rule. So it set it up here
so as you can see that all
Settings are exactly the same as I showed and now it will be applied to the URL all virtual machines in your Google Cloud
Platform account. Let's go back to the virtual machines. We have
Instances and we need to click create instance
create instance
The name you can you can leave default
Okay, what our next step we need to change the boot disk, so basically we need to change the
OS that this virtual machine will use the OS it's the
For example your Mac OS or the Windows, but for virtual machines most of the time
people and developers they use Linux since it's very light and works fast and a lot of
a lot of projects are
Working on the Linux without any problems
So, okay, we need to click change here according to the guide and we will use Ubuntu
This version you can just copy paste it here. Okay, I'm going to find this exact version
224 LTS is it correct LTS
8664 okay, this is correct
And we need to change the size of the disk to 25 gigabytes click select
And our next step is create the virtual machine
Itself, I think the rest of them
The rest of the settings stays default here
So we just need to click create. Let's create it will take some time
To deploy it so as we can see here, it's pending it's creating. Please don't forget to
Switch it off
after the course
Since it will take from you around twenty five twenty six dollars per each month and
You have three hundred dollars as a free trial, but it's gonna end sooner that you understand
That you've figured out. Okay, let's I will take a pause here and when it's done, I will continue
Okay, cool. It's done and we need to click SSH here and it will open you with new window
So what's going on here?
We are connecting to our virtual machine
Hey
Yeah, that's cool. Now. We have the real
Computer somewhere on the Google servers that we can do all the things that come up into our mind, right?
okay, this is the
This is the final step here and with a new video we will go to the part two